Deacon's legs other needs to forget this
basketball game go away
energies playing would be the answer he
can do that very entertaining first half
in Miami for game 3 if he clears himself
mani challenges Olynyk count the basket
and one for Joe L&B he lifted out a file
out of the way when in a Olynyk came
over got a little bit of body and and
one for Joe live beep I like his
patience nice way to lift the defenders
and and one for Jolin beep I like his
patience nice way to lift the defenders
of cheer home team's winning both games
in pita fire three-second made
three-pointer of the night for Joe Allen
beat 2nd block for Winslow he's got 19
points 8 rebounds here's in bead with
Johnson on the ball top shot Joe Allen
bead uses the bank mean a chance to go
up double digits and they left by 11 in
the first quarter impede for three yes
that is a big one JoEllen be that now
he's out there in Johnson's a really
good defender he's up in his grill
there's really not a airspace for him he
but he just rises up at 7 - and shoots
it all